Speaker 1: OK, next.
I want to talk about, Oh man, I don't even
know how to start this.
So last week, I interviewed Andrew Yang, a
former Democratic presidential candidate,
former New York City mayoral candidate.
During that conversation, one of the topics
I brought up was who from the right?
Do you imagine would want to be part of your
third party movement and do you welcome everybody
from the right?
And he answered the question.
And then when he said Everybody's welcome,
I followed up and I said, OK, well, what about
like real extremists like white supremacists?
And he gave me an answer, and I believe that
he sort of botched the answer.
And as a result, this has led to absolute
chaos, including Andrew Yang tweeting about,
Of course, I don't support white supremacy.
And this is a manufactured controversy.
Now, it's not clear from his tweet whether
he's attacking me or people reacting to what
he said to me, but I'm going to play the full
section of the interview for context.
You will see that I was totally genuine in
my question.
It was not an attack.
It was not a manufactured controversy.
It was not a gotcha.
It was just me following up to what his answer
was to my first question.
So let's take a look at the original clip
from last week's interview.
Who exactly that currently considers themselves
to be on the right?
Does Andrew Yang imagine bringing into the
forward party and to kind of make it a little
more specific?
You know, we would imagine that there's lots
of progressive Democrats, more centrist Democrats,
even some folks who really consider themselves
centrist, maybe in the kind of line of even
like a John McCain who like the idea of some
of the reforms you're talking about.
And that all kind of makes sense to me when
I think about people who believe Donald Trump
won the election.
Vaccines, the COVID vaccine magnetize is you
causes autism, whatever the case may be, etc.,
right?
You know, the package of ideas that I'm talking
about.
One, are those people that would even conceivably
say this forward party idea that Andrew Yang
proposes in a coalition with the left makes
sense.
And number two, are these even people that
you want as part of your coalition?
Speaker 2: First, let me say, I want everyone
as part of the coalition, you know, if you
can vote, we can disagree on a lot of things.
It's all to the good.
If we agree on the fact that this duopoly
is not working, it's designed to turn us against
each other and sink us.
So that that's one of the principles of the
Foreign Party is that, look, I can disagree
with you on a lot of stuff, but we can make
common cause on this.
Then we can go back to disagreeing when the
democracy is actually set up to succeed when
they're, you know.
Speaker 1: So let me, I mean, let me ask.
So even I mean to to make it really specific
if people on the right say the Republican
Party is too centrist, I'm an extreme white
supremacist or something like that.
But I think we need to get, you know, we need
single transferable vote or whatever and campaign
you.
You still welcome that because you're on the
same page on that one issue.
Speaker 2: Yeah, if they're going to help
us transition to a more effective democracy.
You know, I don't need to know what their
stance is on things that I disagree with.
People have a sense of where I'm coming from.
OK.
But right now, I believe that there is an
existential threat to the country as a result
of the greatest design flaw in the history
of the world.
OK, so
Speaker 1: his answer, which I don't think
was a great answer, created a buzz.
And a lot of people saying, Wow, Andrew Yang
welcomes white supremacy.
Some people taking it out of context.
Some people just saying, Wow, that wasn't
a really great answer.
So Andrew Yang ultimately took to Twitter
a few days after the interview, where he wrote,
quote, I didn't think this needed stating.
But people who hold ideologies such as white
supremacy that are antithetical to grace and
tolerance are not welcome in the forward party.
Our movement for democracy reform is fighting
to diminish harmful extremism.
Now, remember in the interview with me, he
said that it would be fine, that they would
be welcome as long as they're OK with ranked
choice voting.
That's what he said.
I didn't trick them into saying that.
He followed up with another tweet which said,
quote Relatedly, this kind of manufactured
controversy is the kind of thing that's dragging
down our public discourse and distracting
us from the true issues at hand.
He gave a bad answer Racist is not the path
to enlightenment now.
I didn't know whether he was accusing me of
manufactured controversy or others on Twitter
of manufactured controversy.
But in response to this, I tweeted, Assuming
this tweet is a response to the question I
asked during our interview, I hope it needs
no clarification that I was not attempting
to manufacture controversy and ask the question
completely, genuinely.
After reading the book now after the interview,
Andrew and I spoke off air for a bit and he
said, Your question about white supremacy.
It actually got me thinking.
And he said he hadn't considered it.
He came up with the answer.
You see him pause when he answers the question.
He didn't say it was unfair or a gotcha or
manufactured controversy.
We had a perfectly nice conversation, so I
hope and am leaning towards.
He was talking about people on Twitter weaponizing
his answer.
Now that being said, I think he just did not
answer the question that, well, if I were
him, the way I would have answered that question
would have been to say, David, listen, I've
denounced white supremacy many times during
the last few years.
It's hard to imagine too many white supremacists
wanting to join a movement led by an Asian
guy, but I can't control to whom these principles
appeal.
And just like any candidate, might end up
with anybody supporting them.
I can't control that, but a my inviting white
supremacists.
Of course not.
Do I think white supremacists will even be
interested in this movement?
Of course not.
That's how I would have answered the question.
He answered it a different way, which was
to say, Yeah, if they want ranked choice voting,
then they're welcome.
So what is this ultimately really about?
For me, it's about.
Who exactly from the right are we looking
to pull in to this forward party?
And we had a good conversation about that,
and I don't know that necessarily more has
to be said, but I'd be curious to your reaction
to the entire exchange.